the year 1840 the whole world is shaken
by some startling news
a vessel the rosalie was discovered in
the vicinity of the bahamas
all its supply of fresh water and
provisions as well as its cargo and
lifeboats were intact
but the crew of the rosalie had
mysteriously vanished in thin air
and the only creature that was found on
board was a canary bird
the year 1918 a cargo ship 165 meters
long
the uss cyclops disappeared in the same
area
not a single passenger out of the 306 on
board was to send out a distress call
both incidents took place within the
area known as the bermuda triangle
and it wasn't long before aircraft
started vanishing there too
but what is it a hyped up sensational
fable
or an unexplored anomaly what is
concealed in the waters of the bermuda
triangle
let's try to get to the bottom of it
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the bermuda triangle is an area in the
atlantic located off the southeastern
tip of florida
part of the triangle's water zone is in
the bahamas
the area itself is between miami the
bermudez
and puerto rico the area covers over 140
000 square miles navigation in these
parts is extremely difficult on account
of innumerable shells
besides frequent cyclones and storms
originate here the turbulence of the
waters here may be explained by the fact
that the bermudas are located in the
open ocean
and should a storm simultaneously begin
in the northern and southern parts
and near the coast of florida the three
storms will collide
thus generating enormous waves
all sorts of vessels were wrecked in
these waters throughout the long history
of seafaring
and the natural disasters responsible
for these accidents are quite
ordinary and are very well known to
mariners who often have to face them in
the open ocean
for example the 165 meter long cyclops
we've already mentioned
is likely to have fallen victim to
lateral waves
there are several facts in favor of this
version
to enhance the capacity of the ship its
bottom was constructed flat
which made it vulnerable to the assault
of lateral waves
it is also possible that the vessel was
smashed by a single gigantic wave
these may suddenly appear even in fine
weather as opposed to regular waves
it is these natural phenomena that are
likely to have caused
this and other vessels to perish in
these waters
as waves of this kind catch up with the
ship abruptly and without warning
the crew are two taken aback to send out
a mayday call in the nick of time
but even one story of this kind was
enough to sparkle instant interest in
the newly born legend that was to spread
across the rest of the world in the
blink of an eye
so there was no way journalists could
overlook this matter
the second half of the 20th century
heralded a stream of unverified
information about the bermuda triangle
in newspapers
and very soon it acquired the reputation
we're used to today
and is firmly lodged in people's minds
as an anomalous
bizarre mysterious place is it such an
unfathomable mystery though
it wasn't only the vanished ships that
were the main cause of interest in the
area
the most sensational incident was the
disappearance of five navy bombers on
the 5th of december 1945.
on reading the story in a newspaper you
would also most likely not fail to see
it as a mysterious occurrence
at first glance it does appear
inexplicable
the flight leader was an experienced
pilot and the flight was taking place in
fine weather
the search for the planes revealed
nothing the only evidence of a crash
being deciphered radio transcripts of
the men
it can be heard that they were
completely disoriented and had no clue
as to their whereabouts
all their compasses seem to have failed
but if one looks deeper into the matter
mysticism and conspiracy theories give
way to something more down to earth
and eventually a perfectly logical
explanation can be found for such air
and water accidents
one of the most popular versions is the
giant waves theory
these may rise as high as 30 meters
it goes without saying that planes
wouldn't be within their reach
but even a truly enormous vessel may
easily be sunk by a wave like that
the point is that a storm at sea may
persevere for several days
if two waves overlap they get mutually
enlarged
and there occurs what is known as
interference that's the special
term for this phenomenon as a result
the size these waves may grow to is
mind-boggling
and even storm-resistant vessels may be
unable to withstand their crushing force
unlike with a tsunami these waves appear
abruptly even in fine weather
so it's downright impossible to see them
coming the fact that hardly any debris
is recovered after crashes or shipwrecks
is accounted for by the nature of the
bottom of the bermuda triangle
its relief is one of the most elaborate
in the atlantic ocean
for one thing a huge trench traverses
the triangle
it is called the puerto rico trench and
its depth reaches 8742 meters
the length of the trench measures 1754
kilometers
and its width about 97 kilometers this
is the deepest point in the atlantic
ocean
besides the bottom of the bermuda
triangle is extremely diverse
and is rich in continental slopes
shelves
shells middle and marginal plateaus
abyssal plains and deep flowing straits
this per se doesn't account for the
shipwrecks but it certainly makes any
search for wreckage practically
impossible
speaking about the disappearance of
planes the key to the riddle may also
lie at the bottom of the ocean
and may have to do with tectonics
seismic activity at the bottom of the
triangle may cause magnetic
perturbations
which in their turn may cause navigation
devices to malfunction
by the way frequent underwater
earthquakes result not only in methane
eruptions
but may also generate infrasound which
in its turn interferes with radio waves
this could be why the electronic
equipment failed and the pilots lost
their bearings
infrasound is also pernicious for the
human psyche
having been exposed to it especially for
a prolonged period
the pilots and seamen may have lost
treason and acted uncontrollably
for example the mariners may have
abandoned their ships
or else lost the ability of navigating
them responsibly
however the version that has most
evidence has to do with gas eruptions as
a result of decomposition of methane
hydrate
in the fields at the bottom of the ocean
these fields are formed after a great
many
years of decomposed organisms
accumulating on the ocean floor
according to this concept big methane
rich bubbles are formed on the water's
surface
their density is low to such a point the
ships cannot help
capsizing and so sink instantly
when methane reaches the surface water
becomes saturated by bubbles of gas
and a ship loses its buoyancy on several
occasions
geologists observed entire oil platforms
submerging underwater
as a result of such eruptions talking
about air accidents
it seems feasible that while floating in
the air methane may cause them to fall
for example the air density could
decrease to such a point
that the carrying capacity of aircraft
could drop as well
and the outer meters would malfunction
it was experimentally confirmed that a
ship really could sink
relatively fast following the effect of
this phenomenon
provided the culprit gas bubble is
bigger than or equal to the ship's
dimensions
interestingly methane hydrate is to be
found in other areas of the global ocean
in the sea of arkotsk for example and
many other places across the planet
unlike with the bermuda triangle however
those
places didn't receive much publicity as
no such outstandingly sensational
accidents or shipwrecks took place there
we can't but admit that many of the
reports about what happens in the
bermuda triangle
are seriously exaggerated and ships and
aircraft do vanish in places all over
the world from time to time
let's try to sum up all the above
mentioned and look at the bermuda
triangle from a different
perspective if we consider it as an area
in the ocean with a high rate of
cyclones and storms
the statistical figures on plane crashes
and shipwrecks shouldn't really strike
us as particularly high
and when people finally get to the heart
of the mata in their investigations of
the causes of those tragic accidents
we will probably see that there is
nothing downright bizarre about it
all after all but while it is still
shrouded in mystery
the bermuda triangle enjoys keen
interest of a great number of people
on our planet earth dear friends
we in our turn are keen not only on
making videos about space objects
but also phenomena we come across on our
own planet
if you're into things like that we would
be grateful if you told us what other
unusual places you would like to find
out more about
even though there are staggering numbers
of fascinating objects in space
our own earth as an object for
scientific scrutiny
is bound to remain in scientists
priority for many years to come
let's keep in touch
[Music]
so
you